pères dans ce journal un débat entre le
prix nobel de la paix 80 l'argentin
terrell esquivel et l'ambassadeur de
grande bretagne en france une semaine
sociale tendue la cgt intensifie son
offensive criminalité une progression
moins forte 180 - des attentats par
explosifs mais aussi plus de vols avec
violence mais à messieurs bonsoir il y à
37 ans tout juste le 7 mai 45 le
troisième rech après une guerre affreuse
capituler dans le préau d'une petite
école de reims devenu collège technique
face à face alors l'allemand jo 2 et la
mecque
eisenhower le lendemain une cérémonie
analogue à berlin et bien c'est cette
date que l'histoire allait retenir pour
marquer la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
cette fête de l'armistice a été
diversement célébrée depuis la
libération
cette année là voilà à nouveau férié
mais non chômé ce qui est un petit peu
différent mais le caractère de la
célébration va s'en trouver changée
serge me serais s'est intéressée à
l'historique du 8 mai 8 mai 45
à berlin le maréchal keitel signe
l'armistice et la capitulation sans
conditions de l'allemagne hitlérienne
six années d' atrocités nazies dans
toute l'europe ses enthousiasmes un an
plus tard l'assemblée vote une loi qui
déclare jours fériés
l'anniversaire du 8 mai de retour à la
tête du pays le général de gaulle fait
voter trois décrets successifs en avril
50 9 avril 65 et janvier 68 qui diminue
quelque peu la portée de cet
anniversaire
réduit à une cérémonie de fin de journée
il faut se souvenir des rapports
privilégiés établi alors entre la france
et l'allemagne de l'ouest entre les
général de gaulle et le chancelier
adenauer 1975 valéry giscard d'estaing
supprime carrément la commémoration du 8
mai désormais seul le 11 novembre
rappellera les victoires et les
sacrifices du pays tollé général
bataille de procédure au parlement en
vain 23 septembre 80 les députés
décident
l'unanimité moins une voix de refaire du
8 mai un jour férié
une décision conforme aux engagements
pris par françois mitterrand et qui
répond finalement à la tente des
parlementaires et des anciens
combattants
nous ne pensons pas que le 8 mai 45 a
été la victoire de plusieurs peuples sur
le peuple allemand
nous disons que le peuple allemand a été
lui même libéré de l'emprise nazis et
que cette libération a été la condition
essentielle de la construction et de la
réconciliation européenne
et c'est dans cet esprit-là que les
jeunes allemands de l'ouest viendront
demain aux manifestations du 8 mai à
paris et voyez-vous c'est aujourd'hui
qu'est mort le dernier général nommé par
hitler à quelques semaines de la fin de
la guerre
valter fang qui est mort des suites d'un
accident de voiture et simon wiesenthal
qui s'est juré de traquer les nazis
partout dans le monde a dit aujourd'hui
sur antenne 2 me dis qu'il doublait la
prime proposée en échange d'informations
sur le lieu où se cache le criminel
joseph menguelet il offre 100 mille
dollars environ 600 me fera la guerre
encore avec le conflit des malouines ce
soir pourtant les combats ont cessé à
parements depuis plus de 24 heures
sur le plan diplomatique les choses
elles n'avancent guère les argentins
maintenant plus que jamais leur
revendication de souveraineté sur ces
îles
une revendication que refuse toujours
aussi vigoureusement les anglais alors
tout de suite buenos aires avec claude
gagné à notre envoyé spécial
négociations ce n'était pas plus
laquelle le peuple argentin attend
peut-être plus inquiet qu'il ya une
semaine
mais depuis il ya eu des morts des
bateaux coulés des avions qui ont
explosé et ici comme sans doute en
angleterre on trouve que c'est inutile
stupide
les journaux ne parlent que de
négociations alors le petit faisons la
paix négocions mais pas les malouines
évidemment de montrer la tête est-ce
qu'on insiste sur le fait d'aller aux
nations unies
section pacifique et juste
parce qu'évidemment nous savons très
bien tout le peuple argentin sait très
bien que les marines natures
mais il y a des on se rend compte que
l'angleterre est en train de préparer
encore des bateaux des avions que
l'arrivée pour attaquer de nouveau est
dans une situation de négociation
ça fait mal a lâché de la pub de la rue
lasserre qui me préoccupe le plus jeune
directeur territorial coloniale au
sénégal à part le nom de leurs candidats
jeunes organismes dont la part dans le
monde pour des sites et leur coloniale
dé sur l'ocré
open
que souhaitez-vous
il a fait à partir du premier arrêt j'ai
fait un désaccord et un gouvernement bis
a fait remarquer qu'il y avait des
moyens diplomatiques pour le faire
l'écho 20e siècle on constate à épiler
us tout derniers développements un
provoquée par la grande bretagne qui
menace désormais d'attaquer les unes et
rj les unités argentine qui
s'éloignerait à plus de 12000 de leurs
côtes c'est à dire pas plus de 12 milles
environ 20 km des côtes argentines ont
pu des simples côte des malouines donc à
un blocus qui s'intensifie et qui ne
devrait pas aider un règlement pacifique
de ce conflit
pourtant les grandes manoeuvres
diplomatiques se poursuivent en ce
moment même dans les coulisses de l'onu
autour de monsieur perez déclare le
secrétaire général je pense qu'il y aura
du nouveau
d'ici à la fin de ce journal avec nous
maintenant dans ce studio
le prix nobel de la paix 1980 un
argentin précisément adolfo pérez
esquivel un argentin que son
gouvernement n'est d'ailleurs pas
beaucoup puisque un amiral de buenos
aires 10 est aujourd'hui dans le matin
nous n'avons eu que trois nobel en
argentine le quatrième je ne le
reconnais pas c'est vous c'est un
terroriste
ceci pour dire que monsieur pérez
esquivel tente en ce moment une démarche
à titre personnel pour faire avancer la
paix il veut aller à londres
et c'est le sens de la démarche qu'il va
faire sur cette antenne auprès de
l'ambassadeur britannique en france qui
a accepté de dialoguer avec lui ce soir
et qui se trouve vous voyez en duplex
avec nous john fréteur donc ambassadeur
de grande bretagne en france monsieur
pérez esquivel pourquoi est ce que vous
voulez vous rendre à londres
une prise vidéo et l'amour qu'il avait
la passion il la recherche de la paix
est le premier objectif poursuit j'ai
appris avec beaucoup de douleur la mort
d'argentins et deux britanniques et le
danger que tout cela représente non
seulement pour la paix entre les deux
pays mais c'est un danger pour la paix
mondiale
mon devoir en tant qu'agente 1 en tant
que chrétien et en tant que prix nobel
de la paix pas ménagé mes efforts pour
tenter d'aboutir à une solution d'ordre
diplomate alors ne sais pas pourquoi
vous êtes venu à paris pour demander ce
visa qu'apparemment pour l'instant où
vous êtes toujours refusé on refuse que
vous rentriez en grande bretagne je suis
certain que le gouvernement britannique
m'accordera ce visa alors on va se
tourner tout de suite vers l'ambassadeur
de grande bretagne en france sir john
frais talent sur john est ce que vous
êtes prêt à accorder ce visa au prix
nobel de la paix 1980 vous savez en
général nous sommes très prêts à
accueillir n'importe qui pour propager
n'importe quelle rue en grande bretagne
mais en ce moment dans la situation
actuelle dans le sud entre en atlantique
on ne peut pas dire que les conditions
soient tout à fait normal donc nous
avons maintenant un système de visa ne
peux pas répondre sur le champ
à la question que vous venez de me poser
mais sur john monsieur perez couvent
elle n'est pas n'importe qui c'est si
c'est un homme qui souhaite faire
avancer les idées de la paix vous ne
pensez pas qu'il faut accélérer ce
système de procédure de visa
vous savez il n'est pas le seul à
souhaiter la paix
certainement nous et que nous souhaitons
après mais non cela questions spatiales
que vous posez
je veux pas comme cela c'est un
programme de télévision accorder un visa
et pour une disons un pays de tradition
aussi libérale que le vôtre ça ne vous
paraît pas utile de faire avancer cette
cause est ce que il y aurait 10 ondes et
des sentiments plus chauvins dans votre
réponse
nos c'est simplement une question de
fait il faudra une décision alors je ne
t'ai pas une décision que l'on peut
prendre dans tous les moments faibles et
là dessus mais c'est ce couvent elle
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire à
l'ambassadeur de grande bretagne france
demander un visa selon la procédure
normale et c'était à buenos aires et par
l'entremise de l'ambassade helvétique
n'ai pratiquement rien à dire tout
simplement que j'espère que cette
question sera résolue
je comprends fort bien ce que dit
monsieur l'ambassadeur à nivelles et je
fais des démarches au niveau
international également de façon ce que
l'on trouve une solution aux graves
problèmes de nos deux pays mais est ce
que vous défendez les idées de votre
pays à savoir la souveraineté de
l'argentine sur les îles malouines
bendahmane et dépend de la façon nourrie
en tant qu'argentin je ne serais pas là
sans répit dernièrement mais depuis
toujours nous avons demandé à avoir un
pas que l'on reconnaisse notre
souveraineté sur les malouines
par ailleurs nous estimons que des
mesures doivent être prises en passant
par les voies diplomatiques par
négociations entre pays
est-ce qu'en défendant ses idées vous
n'êtes pas l'impression de conforter un
petit peu la junte argentine dont les
idées ne sont pas très projet votre chat
baissé à maintes reprises jean planque
j'indique quels étaient les différences
qu'il ya entre la junte militaire et la
position que j'ai dans le contexte de ce
conflit et en ce qui concerne également
la situation interne du pays
mais je ne pense pas que ce fol moment
est approprié examiner ce problème que
je voudrais indiquer quelque chose qui
me semble très important
la passe il ya un autre prix nobel de la
paix irlandais d'une autre gamin et avec
lui nous aurons fait d'une déclaration
conjointe en demandant une interview à
madame thatcher pour que l'on puisse
mettre sur pied des mesures visant une
solution pacifique en tant que prix
nobel de la paix nilsson unis par des
principes pour qu'il y ait la plèbe dans
nos pays et un taux internationale bien
sûr pour ce que cela représente pour le
monde et je pense que c'est une
déclaration qui a été soumise au
gouvernement britannique
et l'on doit tenir compte de notre
demande pour la paix mondiale aux côtés
de sir john à l'ambassade britannique
philip chatenet je pense que l'on
pourrait puisque le dialogue ne peut pas
s'instaurer apparemment entre entre ces
deux hommes et on comprend pourquoi on
pourrait demander justement si la
position britannique évolué ce soir
diplomatiquement nous continuent à
continuer à rechercher une solution
pacifique à ce problème et le croyons
que les portes du secrétaire général de
l'onu est peut-être la meilleure chance
qu'il y avait eu jusqu'ici mais je dois
ajouter et nous a paru à certains
moments que les efforts de monsieur wade
et du président de perrault aussi cela
promettait de faire de prêt une
possibilité aux règles de la faire mais
ce soir monsieur l'ambassadeur vous êtes
plutôt optimiste ou pessimiste parce que
nous journalistes ont l'impression que
vous êtes tous les deux d'accord pour un
cessez-le-feu à condition que vous
reconnaissiez l'un et l'autre la
souveraineté de chaque pays sur les
malouines c'est très difficile je crois
que la paix est plus compliqué que cela
vider nos salles le projet d'une
précédente perron comporte certains
éléments y compris l'idée qu'il y aurait
un petit groupe de pays avec l'accord
des deux parties pourraient proposer
pour contrôler le retrait des forces en
présence pour être proposées comment te
créer un dynamisme et administrations un
intérimaire et puis peut-être pourrait
faire des propositions sur une solution
éventuelle au différend sur le statut
futur de des malouines temps quand tout
cela je crois que nous avons montré une
certaine flexibilité et que s'il y avait
une réponse apportée de la pâte
la part des argentins cela pourrait
avancer les choses
juste l'envié qu'on va se faire s'il n'y
a pas une réponse appropriée de la part
des argentins est ce qu'il existe une
autre hypothèse que de nouvelles
attaques de nouvelles mort du nouveau
bateau coulé disons que nous préférons
de loi la voie négociée mais si la voie
négociée n'aboutit pas bien sûr nous ne
pouvons pas tout jamais laisser les
malouines sous la dictature argentine on
applique chatenet nous allons être
obligés de mettre un terme à ce débat
une dernière chose simplement excellent
c'est ce que vous allez transmettre un
avis favorable à la demande de monsieur
inscrivent elle qui s'est exprimée donc
en direction nos antennes est ce que
vous allez demander à londres de lui
permettre l'entrée sur le territoire
britannique
je veux transmettre la demande qu'il a
fait je ne crois pas que ce soit pour
moi de faire une recommandation là
dessus c'est une décision qu'on prend
dans les capitales cet autre chose merci
en tout cas messieurs d'avoir accepté de
dialoguer sur nos antennes et puis de
conséquence indirecte de ce conflit la
première à caractère disons
internationale puisque l'argentine
propose un réexamen des relations entre
les états unis et l'ensemble de
l'amérique latine et ce dans le but de
faire pays à washington son soutien à
londres et puis en grande-bretagne la
fermeté de madame thatcher lui a permis
d'aider son parti le parti conservateur
a gagné les élections locales
hier en france la première préoccupation
est de caractère social dans un certain
nombre d'entreprises en effet on a pu
assister au durcissement de conflit à
l'origine très souvent comme dans le cas
de citroën
une nouvelle offensive de la cgt qui
organise une journée d'action le 13 mai
laurent carenzo dont renault flins
citroën aulnay les voitures sont
françaises puis de 60% des os sont des
immigrés aujourd'hui il conteste ils
manifestent on les avait un peu oublié
ceux qui réclament aujourd'hui un peu
plus d'argent mais aussi un peu plus de
dignité
conséquence logique du 10 mai ils
veulent que ça change aussi pour eux les
syndicats représentatifs mal implanté
chez citroën ont parfois des difficultés
à canaliser ce ras-le-bol la cgt saisi
aussi l'occasion pour régler un vieux
avec la csl nos delà il s'agit bien
d'une démonstration de force de la
première centrale syndicale de france à
un mois de son congrès l'organisation
d'henri krasucki qui de son propre aveu
perdre des adhérents de restaurer sa
crédibilité
elle veut montrer qu'elle constitue le
fer de lance du syndicalisme français là
où elle est forte comme chez renault
là où elle est faible mais efficace
comme chez citroën elle ne fait
d'ailleurs pas mystère de sa stratégie
l'action du 13 mai que nous engageons y
compris concernant les droits des
travailleurs tombe au moment où à
l'assemblée nationale on va débattre de
l'élargissement des droits des
travailleurs des entreprises
eh ben je dis que l'action des
travailleurs dans ces entreprises à
l'initiative de la cgt va être un moyen
très efficace pour exprimer à ce niveau
leur volonté d'intervenir sur
l'organisation du travail notamment
et puis en définitive d'aider les
parlementaires de gauche à l'assemblée
nationale qui vont se trouver
indiscutablement confronté à une
réaction très vive de la droite et quand
on connaît quand on voit par exemple
exemple de citroën eh bien on peut on a
tout de suite une image de ce que va
donner ce débat l'assemblée nationale
car la démocratie
eh bien elle est à gauche et nous allons
le prouver avec la cgt plusieurs usines
citroën sont bloqués la paralysie risque
de s'étendre
une situation inextricable qui inquiète
le gouvernement au point d'avoir
provoqué très rapidement la médiation du
ministre du travail
la direction de son côté hésite encore
sur l'attitude à choisir
le confie citroën qui empoisonne le
climat social camou cependant bien
d'autres conflits qui pour le moment
n'ont trouvé aucune solution à usinor
dunkerque bien sûr mais aussi à la
société générale où la grève des
informaticiens s'est étendue et
désorganise complètement le réseau de la
banque nationalisée dans ces conditions
l'ouverture la semaine prochaine du
débat sur l'extension du droit des
travailleurs prend une résonance tout à
fait particulière le ministère du
travail souhaite par ailleurs que les
partenaires sociaux s'entendre sur le
financement de l'assurance chômage
jean auroux l'a répété au patronat et
aux syndicats
rappelons que le déficit de
l'indemnisation chômage s'élève à près
de 40 milliards de francs qu'il faudra
combler d'ici la fin de l'année
prochaine plus de 10 millions de
chômeurs aux etats-unis 10 millions 300
mille en pourcentage c'est le chiffre le
plus élevé depuis 40 ans aux états unis
autre chiffre symbole ce soir celui du
dollar il a repassé la barre des 6
francs le voilà maintenant à 5 francs 99
c'est la première fois depuis deux mois
et demi et cela est précisément dû
essentiellement aux difficultés
rencontrées par l'économie numérique un
chiffre encore ce sera le dernier
l'état va acquérir environ un petit peu
plus d'un tiers du capital du numéro
deux français de la pharmacie
roussel uclaf pour ce faire il va lancer
une offre publique d'échangé sur les
actions la société qui avait conclu un
accord avec un géant mondial de la
chimie allemand hoechst conséquences
pratiques l'état va pouvoir mettre sur
pied une nouvelle politique du
médicament c'est un reportage de dix
schwartz et de pierre lepetit
cette entreprise devait être
nationalisée elle ne le sera pas en
revanche le propriétaire de roussel
uclaf c'est à dire le groupe allemand
hoechst participera au plan de
redressement de la chimie française que
le gouvernement va désormais mettre en
oeuvre mais si le gouvernement n'a pas
nationalisées ou c'est du claf
c'est avant tout parce qu'il était
devenu quasiment impossible de le
séparer de son actionnaire majoritaire
l'exemple de la fabrication d'un
antibiotique conçu ici dans ce
laboratoire de romainville en banlieue
parisienne
la fabrication de cet antibiotique du
nom de céphalosporine commence ici dans
une usine roussel uclaf de lieux ville à
quelques kilomètres au nord de lyon
les matières premières achetées le plus
souvent à l'extérieur sont versés dans
un réacteur chimique pour donner
naissance un acide particulier qui sera
à la base de l'antibiotique après
essorage et centrifugation l'acide sur
le trou sous forme d'une poudre blanche
qui est versé à son tour dans des bidons
c'est même bidon on les retrouve à
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de là
à francfort dans la principale usine de
hearst l'acide qui avaient été fabriqués
en france est alors traitée dans les
chambres rigoureusement stérile où on ne
peut accéder qu'en tenue de véritables
scaphandrier
le cycle de production de l'antibiotique
de la famille des céphalosporines est
loin d'être terminée en effet après un
nouveau traitement dans l' usine de
francfort le produit reprend la route
pour revenir en france à compiègne dans
l'oise où l'antibiotique est
définitivement mis en boîte pour être
vendus aux hôpitaux
alors dans ce long processus
franco-allemand qu'elle est vraiment
l'apport de chacun des partenaires
il ya peut-être un avantage une des
caractéristiques des français qui sont
qui ont beaucoup d idées et d'autre part
il ya peut être un avantage des
allemands qui
la discipline nécessaire pour une bonne
organisation de la réalisation
je pense personnellement que le
tempérament français et plus imaginatifs
donc si j'ose dire plus créatifs et le
tempérament allemand plus rigoureux et
n'y a pas de contradiction
je pense que c'est une très bonne
complémentarité
cette coopération apparemment réussie
entre eux que sté roussel uclaf a donné
des idées aux gouvernements n'ayant pu
nationaliser roussel uclaf il a proposé
avec ceux de participer à une
restructuration de la chimie lourde
française et il a obtenu qu'ils
investissent en france en particulier à
lyon dans un centre de recherche qui va
être bientôt créé politiques le sondage
sofres figaro magazine deux points de
hausse pour le président un public 58%
de français lui accordent leur confiance
contre 37% le premier ministre ne bouge
pas 51 contre 43 une courbe semblables
dans le car note mensuelle du matin
magazine dans l'opposition et bien le
tiercé reste jacques chirac simone veil
valéry giscard d'estaing
à l'assemblée les députés ont interrompu
leurs travaux au 8 mai oblige sans avoir
terminé l'examen du projet de loi sur
l'audiovisuel ils reprendront lundi s'il
le faut samedi prochain et ils en sont
arrivés pour l'instant aux deux tiers
des articles
ce matin le député socialiste bernard
chenez un rapporteur du projet de loi
estimer qu'à terme les radios libres
aurait de la publicité
un fait divers qui fait froid dans le
dos un double crime qui date d'il ya une
semaine mais qui n'a été découvert que
tout récemment dans deux maisons
voisines de la station balnéaire de
saint georges de didonne en charente
mérite maritime dominique tierces et
alain ont enquêté sur la mort de ce
couple d'octogénaires la rue coulon à
saint-georges-de-didonne c'est celle des
vacanciers présents trois mois sur douze
seulement une commune habité par
quelques retraités le reste du temps
c'est samedi 1er mai que constant briand
se rend chez ses proches voisins les
montaudon au 14 de la rue foulon comme
ses amis semblent sorties il rentre chez
lui
soir à 9 heures ils n'étaient pas là 10
heures restait pas là alors j'ai appelé
la police
et puis alors j'ai rentré avec la police
en forçant un peu une fenêtre qui était
assez mal fermée on a été dans tous les
pièges on a vu très peu de désordre un
petit peu quand même
puis chez moi on nous vend la salle de
bain la dernière place est à nous
trouver le corps allongé de de madame en
tonneaux la voiture n'est pas dans le
garage le mari a disparu et bien sûr on
le suspecte
quatre jours plus tard on trouve des
corps atrocement mutilé à quelques
mètres de son domicile au 24 de la même
rue le 24 c'est la maison que le couple
était chargé de surveiller en l'absence
de ces propriétaires parisiens le top 6
permet d'établir que le mari a été
assassiné avant sa femme et l'enquète
policière montrent qu'il y avait vu un
seul et même meurtrier dont les mobiles
exacts sont encore inconnues mais ils
font semble avoir disparu ainsi qu'un
pistolet automatique 7 65 qui appartient
à joseph moto dont à saint georges de
didonne
c'est l'inquiétude on a peur d'eux
jamais dans l'appartement
l'avion
en faire déjà notre porte d'entrée de
sur la rue et puis on a une sonnette
alors comme quelqu'un de venir ce nom
puis on a un rôle et directe avec la
police comme ça c'est tout ça
manière pour offrit de justice en cavale
en l'absence de témoin et d'un disent
les enquêteurs sont réduits et des
hypothèses voyez pourtant malgré ce fait
divers tragique je vous le disais en
titre la criminalité violente ensemble
l'année dernière moins progressé que les
années passées regardons les
statistiques
voyez ces deux chiffres
il représente le nombre d'affaires
traitées en france tous crimes et délits
confondus par les policiers et gendarmes
première remarque la progression
n'atteint pas les 10% entre 1979 et 1981
elle était de près de 13%
les vols l'ensemble des vols avec
violence ou à main armée montre en
revanche une tendance importante à la
hausse tandis que les petits délits vol
de cyclomoteur ou bien à la roulotte
sont plutôt en baisse par rapport à
l'accroissement des années précédentes
il est à noter sur ce troisième tableau
que les cambriolages de lieu
d'habitation ont moins augmenté qu'en
1981 même constat pour les résidences
secondaires
enfin parmi tous les chiffres récoltés
ceux des attentats commis en 1980 la
saynète les attentats contre les biens
publics ont diminué ils sont
statistiquement au niveau d'il ya deux
ans contre les biens privés
la régression est encore plus forte
le lozérien ça avance bien vite mr
wendel avance quand même les
destructions autonomistes sont donc
presque calmer les cambrioleurs n'ont
peut-être pas fait autant d'émules en
1981 et que l'année précédente
il n'en est pas moins avéré que ces
statistiques sont à courte vue de bons
arguments pour les chantres de sécurité
d'abord
fort de ces chiffres je dirais cependant
qu'il conforte historiquement l'idée
selon laquelle la france n'est pas un
pays plus soumis à la violence que
d'autres il y a aujourd'hui gendarmes et
policiers confondus 210 mille personnes
chargées de la sécurité des français
alors avec ceux ci et puis cette
nouvelle comptabilité criminelle gaston
defferre peut poursuivre son discours de
fermeté il y a trop de violence c'est
vrai la tentation de plaire à l'opinion
publique est forte électoralement c'est
ici le pari socialiste de changement de
société qui est en jeu la garantie de la
sécurité des citoyens ne doit
restreindre en rien la liberté liberté
avant sécurité l'ordre est inversé
mais le risque supposé est moindre la
gauche peut tranquillement démontrer
la politique contraire ne donnait pas de
résultats plus probants
voilà un sport maintenant en tennis
d'abord la france éliminée de la coupe
du monde par équipe une nouvelle formule
éliminer tout à l'heure par les
australiens au tour de corse et bien en
france et les français
jean ragnotti sur r5 turbo et jean
claude andruet sur ferrari qui se
livrent un duel très serré pour la
première épreuve spéciale de la 2e étape
il bien l'italien bettega sur lancia est
sorti de la route il a été transporté
transporter tout à l'heure par don à
l'hôpital d'ajaccio avec des fractures
multiples aux jambes
son équipier est un den berg était
troisième au classement général
et puis bien entendu le football le
football avec cette dernière journée du
championnat qui s'annonce passionnante
puisque dans à peu près deux heures une
heure trois quarts maintenant on saura
qui de monaco ou de saint-etienne aura
le titre avec vous alain gillot-pétré la
météo pour de vatan vers la chaleur et
bien ce n'est pas pour demain ça n'est
pas pour après-demain mais il est
possible que ce soit pour lundi alors je
vous le dis avec beaucoup de prudence
parce que quand il y en a l'envié de
grosses bêtises sur le temps du week end
j'espère ne pas me tromper cette fois ci
n'est ce pas vous l'avez noté patrick
aussi donc avec beaucoup de prudence
logiquement il devrait faire beau et
chaud lundi
aujourd'hui sachez qu'à 16 heures il
faisait 4 degrés à cherbourg neufs par
an et 17 à cannes alors pour demain la
france et aux extrêmes des nuages sur le
sud est du pays une dépression est en
train de se former la nouvelle est
tombée il ya une heure au pelage de la
carte il vous fait une dépression train
de se former sur la corse et la
sardaigne qui pourrait donner demain des
vents assez forts restent ici des stars
est sur la méditerranée sur la corse et
l'extrême sud-est avec de la pluie et
des orages ou de l'autre côté autre
extrémité au nord-ouest pas mal de
nuages aussi avec de la pluie qui
s'évacuera lentement vers l'est dimanche
partout ailleurs surtout au sud de la
loire quelques vous le matin mais tout
de même c'est plutôt du beau temps pour
samedi pour dimanche surtout au sud est
d'avoir les températures tout arrive ça
monte mais oui sauf sur les côtes de la
manche ça reste de 12 à 13 degrés
partout ailleurs on va gagner 2 à 3
degrés surtout lundi j'espère
et cela m'a libéré de toute façon 19
degrés
notre agenda demain samedi 8 mai trois
minutes supplémentaires levé 6h21
coucher 21h14 c'est la pleine lune et
c'est la lune rousse qui n'a strictement
rien à voir avec la rousseur constaté
des plantes lorsqu'il ya un anticyclone
et pas de nuages la lune n'a rien à voir
avec cela
en fin de matinée l'agra 1945 bien sûr
il à saint désiré le patron de tous les
investisse voilà je vous donne
rendez-vous à 22h50 pour le tout donnait
journal d'hervé claude qui vous donnera
les premières images nous serons les
premiers à vous donner des matches 2
guy laganier journée du championnat de
france avec notamment le match de monaco
qui pour l'instant un point d'avancé sur
saint-etienne et puis le match de nantes
ou bordeaux va jouer sans gardien de but
on verra bien ce que ça donnera
et puis j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain soir à 20h bonne soirée
à tous